sorry i'm late thanks for letting me in
good thing we're allowing late data into
our windows speaking of which let's pick
up right where we left off dealing with
windows and late data in apache beam
[Music]
in the last video we looked at some
sample data and how beam fits that data
into windows with our example data we
set up five second fixed windows and
talked about how some events might not
make it into the window if the watermark
has already passed
data is considered late if it comes in
after beam has already processed the
window so what exactly does that mean
for your data the default behavior is to
drop late data which means it's not used
in any data processing sometimes this
might be what you want depending on your
business logic however if you want your
pipeline to process data that arrives
after the water mark passes the end of
the window you can apply an allowed
lateness when you set up your windows
this option gives your windows the
chance to react to late data if allowed
lateness is set the default trigger will
process the new data and send out the
results immediately
so if we set the allowed lateness to 10
seconds the final event from our example
will still be processed because it's
less than 10 seconds late the result of
this late processing will be sent to the
next step in the pipeline beam uses
watermarks to provide an estimate for
knowing when no more data is expected
for a window and a loud lateness gives
you the ability to allow late data into
the windows when we look at our example
data and the windows after giving 10
seconds for a loud lateness
well that's not quite what we were
expecting is it
it looks like there's two windows with
the same start and end
that's because they're actually the same
window but two different window panes
which is what we call it when a single
window aggregation is output as two
separate elements for downstream
processing depending on how you want to
handle data elements in a window might
need to be processed several times
the actual results from processing a
window are called window panes and they
fall into three categories
early on time and late
up until now we've been dealing with on
time panes which are the unique output
that contains all the received data when
beam considers the window complete
based on the watermark
but this new window pane is actually
late because it has some additional data
that's been allowed into the window
thanks to a loud lateness
when a window has multiple outputs beam
can handle passing on the results in two
ways these two window panes one on time
and one late have the same window
properties like start and end time but
not the same data
this happens when the data is discarded
and beam passes along the new process
data as a separate window pane
if we don't want the data to be
discarded we can set the windows to
accumulate data rather than discard it
allowing accumulating data gives us this
where the late window pane now includes
all of the data from the first pane as
well
instead of just passing along the new
data beam will pass along the entire
aggregation as a replacement for the
previous window pane
ultimately it's your business logic that
will dictate which of these is right for
your pipeline if you want to include
late data deal with late data
differently or discard it entirely
that's all possible through how you set
up the windows in beam
with our example the first window having
two panes means each of those panes
would be sent down the pipeline for
whatever other processing you have set
up one benefit to these multiple panes
is that you can actually process results
before the late data comes in and then
process them again with the late data
we've mentioned a few times what beam
does by default such as the after
watermark trigger but one of the
properties of the beam model which makes
it so powerful is how you can configure
all of the behaviors beam uses these
triggers to determine when to send off
the data from a window through a window
pane and there's lots of options for how
to configure them
again the watermark is beam's indicator
that there is no more expected data for
that window the trigger for a window is
the actual mechanism that sends off a
window pane
after watermark is the default trigger
that's actually responsible for this
which will only happen once per window
after the watermark has been cleared
that trigger will happen no sooner than
the watermark which will then send off
the window pane for further processing
depending on if you're allowing late
data events after the watermark might go
into the same window and eventually
become a late window pane
but after watermark isn't the only
trigger you can use instead of our small
example data what if we were collecting
millions of events over a large window
like 24 hours
having the final data be processed after
waiting the full 24 hours is important
for completeness but that might increase
how long it takes to make decisions
based on that data
thankfully you can use data-driven
triggers and processing time triggers to
get early results
data-driven triggers can take action
based on things like the count of events
in the window
so
even if the window is 24 hours you could
trigger an early window pane after the
first
20 events are processed
in the same way you can use a processing
time trigger to get an early window pane
based on the processing time so if you
want to see some early results after
only 12 hours of processing you can use
a processing tying trigger to get an
early pain
but that's not all
triggers can be composed together for
more flexibility on when you want a
window pane by using after any you can
group triggers together so only one of
the sub triggers needs to be met in
order to tell beam that the window pane
is ready
another common case is to use repeatedly
to have the trigger continue to process
the window as new data arrives
if we take a look at this code this
trigger will happen every time 20 events
are processed or after two hours
it's important to note that these
triggers can be customized but they only
set the minimum requirements for sending
out a window pane especially since beam
is built to do distributed data
processing there might be a bit of extra
time or a few more events than the
minimum
keep that in mind as you experiment with
triggers and customize to fit your needs
so far everything we've talked about is
based on fixed windows that have a start
time and end time and don't overlap even
if you don't declare a window beamus
still uses the global window which is
great for batch jobs but not so useful
when dealing with unbounded data
if you want to use windows that overlap
you can use sliding windows a good way
to describe sliding windows is to think
about doing a moving average if you
wanted to get an average of the number
of events in a 10 minute period but
wanted that average to update every
minute sliding windows would be a good
fit
since these windows overlap any events
in that overlapping time period will be
processed in both windows it's a good
idea to understand how intensive the
event processing is and potentially
perform any processing before windowing
to avoid heavy resource usage
there's one more kind of window
session windows these windows are a bit
different instead of start and stop
times you specify a gap time
this gap time is how long a window
should wait without seeing any activity
before closing using the same example of
mobile device data from before we might
use a session window with a gap time of
5 minutes to automatically create
windows based on when the user is active
if the user doesn't have any events for
5 minutes the window will close and
continue processing so to recap
windows subdivide data in beam uses
triggers to send off window panes which
could be early on time or late
allowed lateness can be used to allow
late data into a window past the
watermark
windows can be fixed sliding or session
and all of these give you the ability to
really customize your processing
pipeline
of course this is a lot of information
and we are just scratching the surface
there's a link in the description below
to a detailed notebook where you can try
out the code for yourself and get
hands-on i definitely recommend you
check it out if you want to learn more
thanks for watching
[Music]
you